meinungsfreiheit steht in diesem grund
gesetzbuch und kunstfreiheit selbst für
so ekelhafte zahlen wie mein körper
definierter als von auschwitz insassen
wenn man darf trotzdem zum kotzen finden
und muss ihn nicht an einem holocaust
gedenktag auch noch mit einem echo
auszeichnet der deutsche rap braucht
dringend eine antisemit preisgrenze wie
die zuschauer und das gehört ja auch zur
debatte was ist kunst der kunst ist ja
nicht nur nicht nur hochkultur wie das
hier
farid bang liest klassiker der deutschen
lyrik mit werken von johann wolfgang von
goethe
vom eise befreit sind strom und bäche
joseph freiherr von eichendorff
es war als hätt der himmel die erde
still geküsst bis hin zu erich fried es
ist unsinn sagt die vernunft ist was es
ist sagt die verfügte liebe farid bang
liest klassiker der deutschen lyrik
kaufs der buren sohn
[Musik]
ja
soweit dr farid bang sein duett partner
kollege bürgerlich felix blume aus der
klassischen gangster stadt düsseldorf
arbeitet da deutlich subtiler hier in
seinem video apokalypse trägt der
stellvertreter des teufels auf erden der
die menschheit kontrollieren soll
an der hand ein ring mit davidstern und
nachdem dieser banker im video beseitigt
ist herrscht auf erden frieden zwischen
ich zitiere modisten muslimen und
christen
das theater noch was achja juden
kollegah selber sagt dass wir eigentlich
nur science fiction also eine zukunft
die er sich erträumt ohne juden halten
aber immerhin gab es von kollege auch
eine muss man sagen fast schon
versöhnliche geste an alle hörer von uns
die jüdische wurzeln haben hier kommt ab
jetzt auf lebenszeit auf jedes konzert
umsonst in den backstage mit uns schön
stellung
es gibt bestimmt einige unter euch die
sind jüdischer herkunft bitte meldet
euch bei mir sagt mir mal ob bus und
bringe euch irgendwie antisemitisch
rüber kam oder ob irgendwas vielleicht
beleidigend
meldet euch immer das ist doch eine
schöne idee finde ich
wer sich beleidigt fühlt er soll sich
melden und stelle sich vor tatsächlich
hat sich ein mitbürger jüdischen
glaubens bei uns gemeldet in dieser
angelegenheit der stand up komiker
oliver polak kollege erstmal vielen dank
für die einladung freier eintritt du
weißt wirklich wie man uns juden kriegt
sache umsonst wegen geldgeil und so ab
jetzt jedes kollegah concert for free
auf lebenszeit
leider kann ich auf lebenszeit bei jedem
seiner konzerte nicht ist aber bestimmt
total nett gemeint man flamingo
schneewittchen außerdem auszug aus
ägypten holocaust und jetzt noch umsonst
auf seine konzerte wie viel leid soll
ein mensch denn bitte ertragen
geschmacksfragen in der 52 und in deinem
video den teufel einen davidstern tragen
lässt dann bist du ganz persönlich
mitverantwortlich wenn jüdische kinder
auf schulhöfen gejagt verprügelt oder
mit gürteln ausgepeitscht werden muss es
denn wirklich immer antisemitismus seien
sind nicht doch wieder auf die themen
für die der rap erfunden wurde
kollege autors mütter abschicken ach ja
auch noch eine technische frage wenn
demnächst die ganzen juden umsonst in
seine konzerte wollen woran erkennst du
eigentlich dass wir wirklich juden sind
wobei so muss es eigentlich passen oder
salon zurück
[Applaus]